I'm honored to be here and I'm even more
honored that so many people showed up
for this little talk about an open
source project I realize it's a little
bit of a pretentious title because it's
mostly what I learned from this open
source project but I hope that you
benefit a little bit from it as well
um what I'm going to be talking about is
essentially everything we are practicing
in our open source project I'm saying we
because it's me and my partner in crime
Jonas near sitting here in the front who
has been helping me for the last four
years
so this is not necessarily about how
great fluent assertion is because nobody
cares about that but more like what are
we using from what are we what am I
using there which practices which tools
and especially how I'm using them at my
day job because I'm a consultant this is
my name Dennis Newman I'm from the
Netherlands which you can obviously hear
from my accent
um
I want to actually give some kudos to at
least one person who's in the group who
is in this audience I think 20 years ago
or something like that I started reading
Jimmy Nielsen's book about
um domain-driven design with the test
driven development in.net that was the
starting point the other one is Jeremy
Miller I think he's sitting there in the
corner and you probably see him
yesterday he wrote a couple of blog
posts a long time ago Jeremy's I don't
know first second fourth law about tdd
and that's what started this whole
little project anyway
so who am I
um I'm in the net space for a little bit
more than 26 years I'm 20 50 uh
September
um I help my clients you know do things
better and of course using fluent
insertions in my libraries but I'm also
looking at architecture and tools and
people and all of that which is part of
the job so in a way my open source
project is a little bit of a playground
you know I try new tools new techniques
see if it works and then I'll start
bugging my clients with that
um
I have a Blog who cares I have coding
guidelines for the last 20 years I have
a couple of Open Source projects and of
course the one that that I'm going to a
little bit be talking about which is the
the subject of this talk fluent
assertions
um it's not 250 million I think it's 244
million something plus one because
somebody just downloaded it he said
which is uh good enough but it sounds
like it's going really fast for some
reason
um by the way you can win a one-year
license for jetbrain's Life a writer I'm
a big fan of jab brains uh by creating a
picture of one of the slides saying
something nice or something nasty that's
also perfectly fine
um maybe that you're just waiting for
the next two talks to be finished so you
can go to the party like I am you can
find me on Twitter Macedon and even Blue
Sky
which is confusing because now I have
three applications to monitor for
messages
so what is the project
um it's something like this you can do
like assertions like that's fluent it's
a fluent API in c-sharp to make your
test a little bit more readable so you
can do stuff like shoot contain you can
do something like shoe throw invalid
operation if you care about that
um other examples like you can do some
some kind of reflection uh checks to
make sure that everything all your code
complies to certain structures
um and the most powerful feature is that
you can actually compare to object
graphs and it will give you very nice
messages
which is what the library is about is it
successful yeah I mean my wife my wife
is actually asking me like why didn't
you earn any money from it like I mean
if it's only one cent you know you
wouldn't have to go away to conferences
and everything so yeah but I love that I
love speaking about my thing is it
successful I don't know I mean yeah the
downloads is impressive but everybody
knows that we're running build agents
and they're just downloading all the
packages all over again in fact it's
running day and night
um but yeah I mean for me one of the the
Special Steps was that it started being
used within the.net framework uh that
started with the SDK and now it's used
everywhere which is pretty awesome and
Microsoft is also doing some interesting
stuff for that
a number of stars and more okay so why
do I think it's a it's it's so
successful honestly I have no clue I
have some IDs though because I like
building packages it's a library not a
framework it means you use it and if you
don't like it you drop it whereas a
framework is something that will you
know you can completely entangle in it
not something you can drop if you start
using identity serve from duende yeah
you're screwed you have to pay for that
although that's a really good Library it
has very clean codes
which is debatable because it's very
subjective but I have some strong
opinions about clean code it's designed
using test driven development it is so
the tests of the project are supposed to
be documentation
um it's used in task code which means
there's no risk for anybody to use it it
doesn't actually affect production code
works with a lot of testing Frameworks
it is supposedly what people saying
improves readability it has a very clear
release strategy which I'll talk about
it's designed for extensibility which by
this by itself is a complicated thing
anybody has built a serious production
product and wants to make it extensible
I guess almost anybody done that
actually meaning the extensibility is
interface on that project so to make it
easy to you know not have to change the
code base the monolithical code base and
allow you to extend it usually it's
pretty hard I think it always backfires
for some reason
documentation great support from me and
Jonas uh
no no no the community is growing that's
really nice to see that has very nice
messages it tells you exactly what's
wrong with you what's wrong with the
code sorry
um
and it has a pretty catchy name I think
that's a bit subjective I would say
um there's other libraries which will
not talk about because they're not
relevant so if somebody starts to use
the library the first thing and I'm
going a little bit through the whole
workflow trying to use that I can
actually see you
um you start with creating an issue so
the first step is you need to go to you
know the repository figure out where is
the code of course there's a beautiful
website and it brings you to the actual
to the the right location this is a
screenshot of the organization structure
there's actually a fluent assertion
organization but the only two libraries
that me and Jonas maintain is fluent
assertion and the Json one the rest are
contributions or people that want to be
part of this you could almost say
ecosystem but it's yeah okay yeah but
there's multiple libraries there's
actually quite a lot of extensions to
that and then you create an issue I love
this by the way anybody using GitHub
yeah of course you are anybody using
azure devops
all these proud people
um what's really cool is uh GitHub is
extremely customizable so one of the
things we're doing is create issue
templates so if you create an issue it's
not just an empty screen that you fill
in you can actually get this and I'm
pretty sure in the back it's not really
readable but it says like I want to
create a book report I want to do an API
suggestion it's a general purpose
feature I just want to go to the
documentation I want to sponsor fluent
assertions because yeah we are investing
all this time we're not getting anything
back except to talk at the NDC
um you can ask questions stack Overflow
this stuff is something you can create
and there's a nice example how you can
do that you can also find that in the
repository so just assume the repository
is kind of a source of all this
information
um this is quite nice actually because
the biggest concern with and I think you
will have that even within your own
projects people putting an issue report
in jira it's never complete you know you
get this half big request something that
doesn't work well you get that also with
your open source project so we try to
streamline Pro that process a little bit
by making sure you you provide the
required information for that this is a
nice way to do that
um
what else so since we get so many
requests and we get kind of you know
frustrated by it we want to actually
have people propose an API because yeah
it's a library and as I said like 250
million downloads means that we have a
certain responsibility to the community
to be consistent to really think about
the API it's not just a stupid little
Library well it's still a stupid level
library but you know a lot of people are
depending on that so we introduce some
kind of mini workflow in GitHub using
labels like API proof the API needs work
API ready for review and we started
doing and when people started to I don't
know submit the pull request with an
entirely big Niche feature that they
worked on for months and then we have to
say like yeah I'm sorry I love I love
what you did but it's not really our
thing so we tried to streamline it and
now what we do is somebody creates an
issue we put a label on it like it's an
API suggestion and then me and Yono
start to chat on it on slack talk about
it maybe even talking about it more
publicly because it's usually an issue
and only if it's approved somebody is
allowed to create a pull request
again that sounds very strict but it's
just like a real project you know you
need to take responsibility for that
code you're maintaining it for other
people in fact you would say because
it's an open source project it's you
even have more responsibility than you
know with these 50 different developers
that you work with we have probably
thousands of developers that depend on
that so that's one thing we do
um design challenges yeah plenty of them
I mean I said we have extensibility
things uh like the first question is do
we want this to be in the library or is
this something that somebody should
build using our extensibility service
and if that's not possible can we
propose that like one of the biggest I
think
um regrets I have and I'm pretty sure
Jonas agrees is that we accepted data
set support in fluent assertions uh dot
net developers remembering data set
there's something from the past right
and now it's back in it and now we have
to maintain it and that was a mistake so
this is something we have to think about
we also have to think about breaking
changes obviously we don't want to cause
that and they can be very nasty like
everything looks fine on the on the
c-sharp level but then we have some kind
of binary compatibility level because
there's a lot of extension libraries
that directly depend on fluent
assertions and if we break something
accidentally that's a problem
um consistency like should all satisfy
throw an exception if the collection is
empty
or should it actually no throw an
exception if the collection is empty
well that is the question
and it's not really consistent sometimes
and we can have like religious debates
about that
um which some people can be very by the
way very aggressive if we say we don't
want to do that because you know it
confuses people
like a real project yeah
records tuples uh how do you deal with
that if you compare to tuples do you
want to use the implicit equals
implementation do you want to compare
the properties and Fields of that yeah
these are difficult decisions in our
little you know bubble that we live in
and async async postfix
I need.net of all of us doing async here
couple yeah you all put all your old
post fix all your methods with async
right
oh not
oh yeah sometimes
or you want to fight about it yeah
probably yeah so we have the same thing
same thing
so if you figured out you created the
issue and you propose something and uh
we accepted that you know we thought
about it we had a good constructive
discussion you started to look at the
repository in more detail so the next
thing is you start to read to read me
because the readme is something you read
um a good read me and by the way this
completely applies to all my internal
projects the client projects I work on
should explain what is it supposed to do
where do I find the artifacts does it
publish npm or nuket packages where are
they where to report an issue how to
build the whole thing what is your what
are the prerequisites what do you need
which visual studio.net SDK or npm
version or yarn or fight or whatever you
need needs to be documented there
because that's what you need you know
there's this little rule like a rule
guideline that I don't know exactly who
said that but if I cannot come into your
organization and get your your
repository cloned build and run in five
minutes something is wrong
it's a bit exaggerated
because I don't think even this one can
run in five minutes but it's a good
heuristic you know it makes you think
like how complicated is it I mean how
many reports have you seen there's no
documentation whatsoever and like how do
I build this thing yeah you go in this
folder then you open that file that's
kind of the thing here and then you look
at the contribution guidelines wow
that's almost like a legal document like
you need to sign in blood that when you
contribute something
um it has grown over the time
but just like all documentation and
guidelines you write within your
organization they kind of organically
grow because you know people make
mistakes you want to improve that so
it's the same here we have good
contribution guidelines that should help
you find existing issues uh the first
thing if you find an issue
um release notes and documentation yeah
we have them they're generated we have
two sets of release nodes we have
release notes generated by GitHub which
I'll show you later on which is pretty
neat but we also have more functional
release notes which are basically
markdown files we maintain
um we also have like functional
documentation that's all markdown I'll
show you later on how we how we build
that and uh yeah well actually you can
see that this is the markdown script
um so in terms of everything is CLI it's
git so what tools do I use that's a good
question because it can be a pretty
religious debate whether you want to use
CLI commands for kit or a UI actually I
use a lot of different tools I use
Powershell obviously Windows terminal I
use
um what else Powershell I mentioned it
already
um I use all my Porsche
which probably a lot of developers that
love terminal things know because you
get nice colors I like colors looks very
professional you know no no
I use p is readline because Powershell
is a bit limited so I want to be able to
go back in my history you know that kind
of stuff because I type a lot of stuff
there and I actually and this is one of
my uh my most um which which I really
love and change the way is um Phil hack
you probably remember him from nougat he
now works for git flow no I don't
actually know he works to get up anymore
but he wrote a couple of aliases and git
that makes it very easy to push at local
changes like I can make some local
changes then I do get safe which just
takes whatever is a market working
directory creates a temporary commit
then I do kit push and when I'm done
like the next day I want to continue I
just do get undo which basically unrolls
that temporary commit and I do that all
day long so I keep amending my changes I
don't even care about the commit
messages because at the end I'm going to
clean up my commits because I love clean
Source control history and there's a
wealth awesome little git aliases that
you can get from that
if you can't find you can always say
ping me afterwards and next to that I
use Z location which is a nice add-in
which allows me to really quickly jump
to location I can probably even
demonstrate that because I have a
Powershell like let me open a Powershell
you see all the nice colors I wasn't
supposed to do live demos but you know
what
it's just NDC so what can go wrong
so Powershell and you see and now I can
say I want to go to fluent and it jumps
right at at the location if I want to go
to different location it just remembers
where you are so it's like a powerful CD
which I use a lot
because I use a lot of Cl commands
but not only because I'm also like I
like gooeys as well
I mean yeah you should use Best of Both
Worlds right some tools are better like
clis are better for quickly pushing my
changes but I use so hello get Kraken
which I love working with because I also
like to clean up my commits you know I
unroll I start to do interactive rebases
I undo things because I like clean
history so it's perfectly fine to have
both
some technical patterns
editor config I use that a lot we use it
a lot for structuring the code base
making sure that you know everything
aligns properly then we use two spaces
instead of TAPS notes four spaces or is
it eight spaces what is it again
um
notes four of course it's four spaces
right no oh
sorry I'm not going to do that
we'll do that after after we had the
first couple of beers we can fight about
that anyway
um doesn't matter as long as you do it
the way I want to do it which is for
spaces but the other config is very nice
because of course it works with visual
studio and all the other tools Ryder but
you can also extend it heavily like a
lot of extensions that I'll talk about
uh can be used as well by the way it's
interesting I'm a big proponent of rider
for some reason and I have not been able
to explain that Jonas actually prefers
Visual Studio
um so in a way that's a good thing it
basically means that the code base can
work for both people
okay what else uh yeah analyze us we
love analyzers because as you probably
all know developers make mistakes I make
mistakes yonos continuously corrects me
because I'm lazy you know I'm at the
conferences and trying to make some
changes there's some beautiful analyzers
that you can for free the Russian
analyzers that are part of the Net
Framework then you have Russell Nader
and this is the one that I never managed
to like pronounce
museum2 dot analyzer
um those are very useful because that
make your call easier like it will for
example make sure that your XML comments
are properly formative not like I'm not
talking about inline comments but like
proper documentation that it looks
correctly that all the references in the
external communication require Community
comments are correct because yeah people
rely on that if you're building a
library and I'm building a lot of
libraries internally in my project as
well you know to create decoupled and
everything this is a nice feature but
also stupid things like using link
incorrectly I think I saw a chat
somewhere from Jeremy and some other
people actually it was um Danielle
talked about performance of linked
um the analyzer would actually detect
that and help you use more optimized
versions of Link or even use extensions
or static methods that are much faster
than this link statement
nested conditional statements you know
the the question mark and then you have
a semicolon you know to choose between
two options
so there's apparently people
in this world that love to Nest them
so you like I see some people wondering
like oh crap
and there's even there's even like
criminals that want to go three levels
deep
okay not in my world or not in our code
base
um long methods the final long yeah we
can have a discussion about that I have
an opinion about that uh it's not seven
methods by the way seven statements
that's a bit too much but by the way you
can also do this with sonar Cube and all
the other tools but uh this is nicer
because you get immediate feedback and
simple things like simple type by file
uh and you and throw in the correct
exception types that actually was
interesting we found some mistakes
from people in the past me
um and proper async support that's also
nice to actually use it correctly like
you know have a method that returns a
task and then you're not awaiting it
I mean that that is wrong right and this
is something that a wrestling analyze
can help
um naming and grouping of tests that's
another thing
so I don't know if it's visible all the
way in the back but we have this class
it's called reference types assertion
specs so I'm a tdd addict and I call
things specs to emphasize that these are
specifications and then we have these
very long names like when the same
objects are expected to be the same it
should not feel fill that's quite long
and that was a big proponent of this for
a long long time
um
I actually started to change that now
we're grouping things we're grouping
things by for example the fact that this
API was if you go back is about should
be same as so we basically create a
nested class to name or to group all the
tests that are belong together because
we have a lot I don't remember exactly
how many there are like 25 000 or
something 25 000 units as we have which
is cheating because we have six.net
Frameworks but it's still a lot still a
lot so now it can be a little bit
shorter like when two variables are
referring to the same object it should
not fail well we already know that the
context of this is bcms so we made it
shorter we've been looking at all kinds
of variants like should succeed but then
somebody said like with when and shoot
there's just noise it's just ceremony so
these days we stick to very short names
reference to the same object are valid
reference to different objects are
invalid which is like pretty concise but
it's still functional correct and it
doesn't describe a desire it describes
more like effect
and it's totally fine if you do
something else but I I kind of feel like
this is we found a nice optimized way to
represent test names
um what else documenting exceptions yeah
who does that by the way in Java that's
required
um we're doing it now I still have some
doubts whether we should have done that
but this is typically a design uh
discussion you have like online with
people like is this useful yeah but it's
useful to know which exceptions you're
throwing so now we're doing it we're
using the um the exception here
exception C ref argument zero
and then it provides you information a
nice thing is if you then use your
pop-up or your intellisense you get all
the information here which is useful
um directory build.props which is a net
specific thing is a nice way to make
sure that all the projects in your
folder have the same Imports which we
use a lot I don't know if you know about
that but it's something reasonably new
it makes it a lot easier
faking time which doesn't exist yeah we
have a lot of methods and I use the same
concept also in my clients projects is
that you sometimes have to deal with
time with clocks and delays and stuff
like that and you can find the examples
in the code itself but we created a
little abstraction sometimes by the way
I use delegates for this to say that we
want to be able to delay the time and
then we have a dummy implementation in
our tests I think there's an example
here that you can look at this makes it
easier to yeah so that you don't have to
put sleeps in code in test code because
I've seen that sleeps and test cards you
shouldn't do that right no you shouldn't
do that no
what else
um bdd style testing yeah so
as you saw maybe before we use a lot of
these arrange act asserts and I use that
everywhere which is pretty well suited
for most of the test cases you know you
have the range where you set up the the
the setup code your initial state of
whatever you're testing then you have
the access basically to emphasize what
you're doing here you're invoking
something on the subject on the test and
then the assert obviously is to verify
the outcome
sometimes you're dealing with classes or
subjectional tests that are more
orchestrational and those cases I'm
actually switching to more like a bdd
style time
so what you see here is like a given
and then a one here some when and then
basically the fact this is using chill
that's another Library I'm maintaining I
didn't create it myself by the way
um which worked quite nice because it
automatically disposes everything that
needs to be disposes at the end
um and makes the code a little bit more
readable
I can't imagine if you see that like
that's a lot of text of course it is but
if you look at more the concrete
examples it's very nice this is the
class on the top of it given temporary
Global assertion options is derived from
given when done and the dispose will
clean up something
um if you have more complicated
scenarios you usually create all kinds
of objects that you have to dispose at
the end they have to clean up at the end
and the nice thing about chill is that
will automatically do that for you again
that's one style there's never sometimes
you need the more the range act assert
another cases there's this bdd style can
be more useful again options
uh what else feeding data to tests yeah
if you anybody using action it
oh a couple of people are there any
non.net developers here
sorry about that
no no I mean that you're in this talk
note that you have to
um but there's something reasonably new
called like like theory is a nice way to
call the same test method with different
sets of parameters in the past these
were all untyped they were all of type
object now you have something called
Theory data which takes a generic type
parameter that you can use in your test
which makes it a little bit more time
safe it's not it's not like it's not
going to change the world but these are
the Little Gems that make it a little
bit easier in your test code and you can
see how you use the member data sorry
member data here name of join using
writing style something like that it's
this small thing it's not that special
but still
um another thing is somebody was saying
like why don't you never go to you know
talks about what's new in c-sharp or
something that's actually very nice
because I'm using an IDE that teaches me
that it will continuously tell me like
hey you know what you can use this new
feature to make your code more readable
uh Jonas is also very active on that
sometimes we go overboard and something
doesn't actually make it more readable
and then you undo that you know not
everything is great if everything new is
great
but for example here you can see
examples where we were actually using
something like a return If the previous
charge and Ampersand and the statement
length is larger than two and the the
second but last statement item in the
array is a dollar and then but one is an
ampersand and now in the new FC Shoppers
you can just say the statement is
comma plus the last two things which is
just a new c-sharp feature which is
quite nice actually it makes the code
more readable but you need to be aware
of that of course
the same here with uh what is this I
hear like the method expression is
unequal to uh it's even too complicated
to read but in the end it's just saying
it should not be
an object which method name has a
certain value and you have a constant
expression this is something that an IDE
like writer will actually teach you I
guess it's the same thing will happen if
you have visual studio with reshapa
um but yeah the idea is that makes your
code more readable and we use that
everywhere
if you don't use these tools and again
I'm not paid by the jet brains in any
way but I've seen a lot of code bases
where people don't use the tool rosalite
that will by the way also help but it
will actually teach you the language and
try to teach you how to get the most out
of the language which is what we want of
course
and also make it easy to refactor here
like there's an example where we use a
special attribute to emphasize that this
match
rack X actually takes a regular
expression and if you do that then your
IDE might actually use that and when you
type a regex will provide you with you
know pop-up information about that regex
makes it easier to read you can also go
to regex101.com to to test your regex
which I use a lot but that's that's a
nice feature to do that as well
um this is kind of special like you have
all these new features and newer
versions of c-sharp but they often rely
on also specific.net Frameworks but what
if you're still stuck on an older
version of dotnet like dotnet framework
4.8 or something like that and you still
want to use newer c-sharp features it's
interesting because some of these
features only require you to add a
couple of dummy or not dummy plus but
certain classes to your project in a
certain namespace and then certainly
your compiler will understand that and
we've done that in the past like I don't
know any real good examples of that but
at the top of my heart
um but we've done it in the past and
there's actually a nice Library called
polish shop and when you do that it will
implicitly add generated or provided
classes that will that basically light
up all these new features and it's smart
enough to understand like which version
of the.net framework you're targeting
and then suddenly you can use all these
shiny new Tools in your old Legacy
successful of course monolithical
database product system
why am I saying database
the other thing that and this is more
design thing is that I really care about
how things depend on each other and
there's a there's a bunch of rules and I
think it's the book is also it's a book
it's called principles of successful
package management which is kind of the
solid principles but then on the package
level which we really try to follow
influence assertion as well and by the
way I use that everywhere
um and it's very simple every component
package or boundary
should only depend or it should only be
used by the consumer as a composition
thing I don't like inheritance anymore
it creates a lot of coupling it's not a
bad thing per se but inheritance tends
to actually make things real to couple
and I don't like coupling
um the next thing is you should only
depend
on a package which is more abstract than
you
so if you follow that rule so if you
depend on something that is more
abstract then you're totally fine or
more stable that's another thing
so this is something that really changes
the way I build my systems these days
so whenever I have a component and even
if you do a dependency injection as long
as you depend on something that's more
stable or more abstract and things that
are abstract are usually more stable you
should be fine it avoids this whole
ripple effect this is a very simple rule
actually
also if you have an optional dependency
that not everybody is going to be using
then you use a special package a
dependency package your component or
whatever you call that so this
dependency package here actually make
sure that this package does not have to
depend on this optional dependency this
is the one that does it now look at look
look at the errors the dependency
package actually connects both together
instead of the other way around
also there's a couple of other rules I
don't think I have them here yeah
anything
that you not always use together here
you should put in a separate package
so if you're for example test support I
don't know you have some library or
internal components because you adopt
inner sourcing your company and that
component provides additional
capabilities that you do not always need
to use when you use the main package
that for me is a signal to put it in a
separate package because that will help
reduce this ripple effect it will also
help that you have to ship a new version
of the main package if that auxiliary
package has actually changed it's
completely unrelated so it's almost like
the increased cohesion ID and open for
extension sorry yeah close for close for
closer modification hope for extensions
it's a very simple rule yes you'll end
up with a lot more packages or
components but it makes your life a lot
easier and finally no circular
dependencies that should be obvious
right
the other thing is is design patterns
anybody remembers this book
has ever read it or is it just on your
desk
it was Reddit
honest come on
it's very old it's actually pretty good
the problem is that a lot of developers
see that as a kind of Truth and of
course people don't read books anymore
they read on epaper or they watch
YouTube or plural side training about
this
design patterns are really awesome
because they're communication technique
if I tell you I have using an adapter or
it's a Singleton or it's a strategy then
hopefully if you experience enough you
know quite well what that means and
that's the only value of design patterns
so we are we are using them obviously
influence assertion I'm using that in my
projects but the guys that wrote this
book there were guys right you know all
guys actually 10 years later or
something I heard told everybody like we
should have called it refactoring to
watch design patterns it's not a goal by
itself nothing that we do solid is not a
goal it's just a means to an end
so we have been refactoring the code
base internally and using the strategies
for example strategy pattern to
emphasize that this is a particular
implementation that you know what kind
of solution to expect
so what about building and testing
locally okay let's start with something
the first thing I'm using and maybe if
you were in the the lightning stock
you've seen it it's nuke
nuke is a c-sharp build agent uh built
sorry build Library created by Matthias
cork maybe he's here I'm not sure
actually
um from jab brains which basically allow
you to write your build script in
c-sharp which is nice because I don't
like writing in other languages I used
to do a sake which is Powershell cake is
something similar but it's a half-bake
solution a nuke is pretty nice you can
you can get like information like this
let's show you it's probably not
readable at the end but it shows you all
the Targets in that script and it can
even display a plan you can see how your
old build process looks like you can run
it locally and this is an example how it
runs what it looks like
so it's just C sharp it's just a nice
way and it means you you can refactor
your build script you can evolve it with
your code base you can run it locally
you run it on your build agent whether
you use team City or GitHub actions or
Azure pipelines the principle is the
same it keeps your yaml to a minimum
really to a minimum because some of the
people that know me know that I do not
have a real good relationship with yaml
um actually I hate it
um
yeah and this completely avoids that by
the way something similar also exists
for cloud deployment it's called pulumi
which I use not on Flow Distortion but
it's a similar idea which basically
keeps you at the yaml held in the Json
hell of terraform you just encode in C
sharp you can debug it you can put
breakpoints in it you can refactor
things you know you can rename things
you can even read it which is not that
unimportant
um and it's it's very extensible I mean
you should definitely check it out I'm
using it everywhere
yes there's a risk that for me this is
the new golden Hammer that I'm going to
use everywhere but yeah we all have
something like that
um what else approval tests yeah so
a big issue when you build when you
build components or packages or
libraries is that as a contract and that
contract is sometimes implicit a lot of
developers don't realize that but for me
it's explicit I really want to make sure
that the API is completely protected and
I don't accidentally break it especially
if it's a bigger code base it becomes a
bit of an issue so what we use is public
API generator which produces a text file
representing the contract of a
particular project and you can specify
exactly how it's supposed to use what
it's supposed to export whether to
include internal things stuff like that
um and then we and we actually have a
build step and a nuke thing that you
just saw that does that and then we use
verify which is another open source
project to compare it and basically if
somebody accidentally breaks the
contract even ourselves it will generate
a new text file do the comparison and
tell you like it's a unit tester thing
that will verify um that that you broke
the contract sometimes you do it on
purpose and that means you actually will
commit that new generated file into
Source control as part of your pull
request you can see the change this is
really awesome because we started using
everywhere especially at the the my day
job we're building a lot of
extensibility points very dangerous to
break something sometimes developers do
not realize especially with monolithical
or not monolithical but spaghetti code
basis you know that we're all working on
every day because nobody's doing what is
it green or is it Greenfield project
it's very useful very powerful as well
and as an example what it looks like
what else benchmarking yes of course we
do benchmarking so we use benchmark.net
we don't use it regularly
uh because yeah running those on a build
agent is not completely reliable these
build agents we are not do we do not
control we use GitHub actions for that
but it's an extremely useful thing to
identify certain performance bottlenecks
um like one of the most complicated
features in fluent assertions is the
ability to compare to object graphs
there's a lot of functionality behind
that yeah sometimes we introduce a bug
like somebody's saying hey we actually
have a we used an array with a thousand
items and now certainly the thing the
unit test takes one minute to complete
yeah then we have used profiler by the
way I didn't mention the profiler but we
use these things then on our local
machine to compare for example and
improvements like many many benchmarks
which are very useful to do that
probably you've seen I think Scott
Hanselman also blocked about it at some
point that usually you know increases
the number of downloads for something it
should actually talk about fluent
assertions
I'll ask him he will know me he will
ignore me as usual uh what else yeah so
this is the output it's completely
unreadable by the way you have to really
study that but yeah if you're dealing
with performance you need to study that
anyway
documentation
this is the website
it's nothing more than a jackal template
I use minimal mistakes
um which is something that is built as
part of the build pipeline I can run it
locally so all the documentation is
written of markdown and that's a nice
reason for that is because if somebody
creates a feature we want the that
person to also include documentation
change that we need for that
um
in my internal projects we do something
similar so we have a lot of reusable
components and libraries and we want to
make it very easy for people to use that
so that's how I look at my own Library
so we build a documentation site for
that there's lots of different ways I
was being told at this conference
there's another one uh doku showers or
something that is kind of similar I need
to investigate as well to make it better
yeah and we generate the website
essentially when the progress gets
merged to the master Branch then
automatically GitHub will pick it up and
we'll refresh the website which is nice
because we don't like writing
documentation but at least if it's
coherent it's consistent with the code
changes makes it a lot easier instead of
putting it somewhere on SharePoint where
you will never find it back oh this is
recorded okay
there goes my MVP status
um
yeah this is a Juggle documentation site
spell checking that's a pretty neat
thing of course because developers make
spelling mistakes we're not we're
non-native English speakers including
myself I'm Dutch you can hear that so we
use c-spell which is again a little neat
gem it's an AMPM package which makes our
whole build pipeline a bit more
complicated but it's still part of the
build script and it will basically
compare or make sure that all our
documentation including the release
notes do not contain spelling mistakes
who cares uh it's me a bit nitpicking
sometimes
actually we often get pull requests
where somebody corrects their spelling
mistakes well that saves you some time
of course
uh you see the output it's an mpm pack
as I said it uses node.js or yarn in
this case
uh what else yeah review merging pull
requests that's the thing
so the biggest problems with pull
requests that you receive from a
community or pull requests I received
from from my colleagues at my client
projects is that sometimes they produce
a pull request that we definitely don't
want
and it's very hard to say no especially
if you're an open source Community
saying no to somebody who likes your
library and wants to contribute that but
you have the feeling like it doesn't fit
there it's too Niche or it's something
that will hurt too much in later on you
have to say no similarly the internal
package that we built that I built at
the projects there's always some some
developer that wants a neat feature
there you sometimes you have to say no
but you have to be polite
it doesn't mean like oh I'm not going to
do it because it's open source or I have
to do it on private time no no something
you have to explain that that's
perfectly okay it's quite hard I think
there's a lot of a lot of people wrote
about this this problem of saying no to
contributors
but by the way I'm not that difficult
I'm Dutch and we're very direct so we
just say no
usually not not with just with a little
bit more words
uh clean Source control history this is
something I really care about I want in
the history of every repository that are
responsible for as an architect both
influential Services as my projects I
care about being able to go back into
the history and understand why something
was changed how often did you go into a
code base you found some code changes
you're trying to figure out why was that
done why did somebody increase the
command timeout for a SQL command from
15 to 30 seconds
and then you know do blame and then you
find the commit pointing to a pull
request and get up or actually devops
and the title of that commit is increase
the command timeline for 15 to 30
seconds
right that's very useful no it needs to
be a why
or this pull requests or these comments
like oops I made a mistake or you know
test or review comments or something
like that
I really care about that so I really try
to train people how to use interactive
rebases how to use a proper git UI to
you know interact with to actually group
related changes give it a functional
title X you know the why of the change I
want to know why was that command time
increased was it some kind of
performance issue that you actually
solved in the wrong way by hiding it
with an increased timeout that is kind
of information that you should not be
that you will not be able to get back
having that in the commit is useful
because I don't know about you but I
worked on a project for like 12 years at
a client and we moved from Team
Foundation server to get up
to azure devops I've got to help us and
probably back to GitHub all of this
history is gone the commits is the only
history you have left so care about that
put some information in there it's not
that difficult if you want to know how I
wrote a blog post about it it shows you
how you can use all these git save and
get and do things that I talked about
earlier with a proper UI and build it
very nice it doesn't take you that much
time a couple of minutes will also make
your reviewers happy because they don't
have to you know find this one
functional change between these other
100 files where you refactor things or
move code around
um and definitely don't force push the
developer
to develop well get up actions I
probably don't have to explain that
everybody that is doing well maybe I do
but get up action is basically github's
build engine which technically I think
is the same as Azure devops these days
even the build agents are the same
um we have a pretty simple yaml script
here
um it's longer than what you would
expect with given what I said earlier
about nuke but that's purely because we
need to build for multiple dotnet
Frameworks which makes it a little bit
more complicated
um yeah you see the output nothing
special here but I thought I'd mentioned
this code coverage oh
that's a sensitive topic
90 95 percent
a hundred percent
well actually
um I don't think you can see that
oh crap uh sorry
oh
that's what you get when you do test
driven development
and we're completely not obsessed about
this now
the thing is code coverage is useful
but you have to be very careful that
you're not going to be treating it as
some kind of goal and most definitely
don't use the kpi in your management
dashboard or something like that I've
seen companies do that code coverage is
just an indication how well you covered
your your code with tests you know
whether 90 is the under is the lowest
value that you want to have that's up to
you I do think if a code base has
something like 35 then I'm worried then
there's room for improvements 80 is
probably okay
and we just started as soon as we
started using a coverage tool because we
haven't used that for a while
um it started to increase structurally
you even found contributors that were
also apparently so um let's say um
obsessed or picky you know about this
and started to contribute Pia pool
requests with unitest that we were
missed that we had missed if you're in
an Enterprise world you probably use
something like Sony Cube which will do
the same thing
it's useful it has its purpose but be
careful with it don't share it with your
boss
unless it's really that great then you
can ask for a raise maybe I don't know
For Eyes review yeah that's what we do
because
um as I said we're with the two of us
mostly
um yeah we just have different views on
things and not in a negative way but
yeah um I'm a bit more like I look at
usually at the bigger picture I'm more
I'm more easily satisfied it comes with
age you know turning 50 almost you don't
care about all the details anymore no no
it's just that yeah you accept sometimes
that your code base cannot be perfect
and fortunately a yonos is can be
something a bit more looking at the
details which helps me to be sharp again
that's totally okay and that will happen
in a real project called I didn't
mention that by the way I use emojis in
my pull request reviews why to share my
frustration and crying all this no no uh
no it's cool because I'll shed a link
later on emojis helped me Express
uh whether a comment that I make is
really important or not sometimes I'm
nitpicking and I know it myself I just
make it very explicit sometimes it's a
seat I literally use the the the the the
symbol the emoji of a seat to emphasize
like you know what you don't have to
change it right now but I want you to
start thinking about that or maybe it's
something for myself
sometimes it's a cross like you really
um are violating our I don't know design
guidelines sometimes it's a question
like maybe we should talk about it it's
something that I'm not entirely sure
this is correct which helps me but also
helps the contributor or the the persons
the developers that work with understand
what I mean because I had Junior
developers at my projects that thought
that every comment that I make because
I'm the architect has to be resolved and
that was not my goal I just want
sometimes people to think about it
I mean it starts with nitpicking and at
some point they'll become pissed off and
then I'll make it across now you have to
fix it but it's very useful by the way I
should have mentioned this
Auto merging which is nice I think every
build engine has that these days even
Azure devops even though it's always
behind
so then we have the Final Phase which is
the releasing
obviously we use semantic versioning
if you're not using semantic versioning
it's three numbers three digits are not
treated with three numbers the first one
indicates whether there's a breaking
change the second one means it's
non-breaking there's new features there
might be bug fixes it's primarily new
features and the last one is this book
fixes which creates it's a communication
technique again if you have a package
and you have 1.2.0 and there's a version
called 1.3.0 you are safe you can safely
use that because what's the biggest
issue with a lot of Legacy code bases is
that they don't update their package
anymore
whether it's npm or nuget or something
like that with this if you know that the
package follows the semantic versioning
rules you know what to expect you know
it should be safe should no guarantees
of course to upgrade that from one to
two that's a big thing
also means that as a developer of a
component of package you have a sort of
responsibility I mean we are currently
at version 6 of fluent assertions moving
to seven is a big deal
I mean it's also opportunity we can get
rid of a lot of the bad choices that we
made but it's a big thing also means we
have to support an older version the
same thing so we accumulate all these
potential changes into the next version
so do that also in your internal project
very useful
git flow or a proper branching strategy
is very important whether you use git
flow or trunk base or GitHub flow or one
variant use something that's described
by the industry and use the same naming
standards like if I see Repository
with a branch called main or master and
develop and support and release then I
know it's git flow and I know what to
expect I know the develop is the one
that's currently being developed I know
that the release branch is currently
being stabilized and I know that support
represents a previous major version of
the master Branch again communication
makes things obvious you know the
principle of least a price is part of
that we do that as well by the way
influence searches we use Git Version
for that that's a tool a.net tool that
will try to look at the browsing
strategy at the tax in your commit
history and generate numbers you get
something like all of this
nuke also supports that out of the box
and we use that to number our new cut
packages to update the build number that
you see in your build agent all this
kind of image is extremely useful you
don't have to deal with this yourself
there are tools for that
uh yeah that's the example with nuke you
basically have a read-only property
called get version and that will be
populated with all the information that
you need in your build process
um releasing yeah very easy you go to
GitHub you say I want to release
something you fill in a number and
that's it however there's some nice
features in there that we use heavily is
for example automatically generating
release notes a lot of people still
generate like they use jira or something
like that it's very easy to generate in
fact if you use a template you can tell
GitHub that if you put certain labels on
the pull request it will automatically
group them in a correct way you can say
like okay this is a this is an internal
change this is a new feature this is a
bug change and your grid listeners will
automatically group things that's very
powerful
you don't have to write that yourself
anymore I don't think Azure devops has
something like that maybe it will never
get that that's nice and it
automatically generates like hey there's
a couple of new contributors to this
repository
um uh you can get the full change log so
with all the commits and poor questions
that's nice also gives credits to people
and you don't have to do anything for
that comes out of the box
and the final thing is nuget reserve
prefixes which is not really relevant
for internal development but can be very
relevant for external development so we
basically were somebody from nougat
reached out to me and saying like hey
actually would you want to make it a
reserved prefix which means nobody else
can push a package to nougat with the
fluent assertions prefix only I can do
that and Jonas can do that
it's a nice little thing makes your life
a bit easier people cannot impersonate
you or something like that
if a project is small you don't care in
our case we do care
um yeah I think that's about it oh yeah
we're not done of course not every
project still has to do things
what else well this whole naming thing
that I talked about with the grouping
and and the short fact-based units of
course the code base is not consistent
it's a real project just like all the
stuff that you guys are building every
day we still have to have to clean it up
we also want to get rid of some of these
Niche features
um like as I said that the rules of the
principles of package management we
haven't been that consistent on that so
we still have some stuff to decouple and
move it into separate packages capturing
design guidelines who is actually
capturing design lines in their code
base in their projects
like nobody like a nice page somewhere
that describes the rules that you have
to follow
or markdown file somewhere or you're
just afraid to ah see one person is a
professional here
um no but we have them as well but for
us they kind of evolved over the time
and I still have to find time to write
something and I don't like writing no
that's a lie uh by the way if you use
fluid distortions you may know these
nice like you can do 12 December
brackets 2022 stuff like that we want to
actually make it a separate package
because yeah it's an extra feature
shouldn't be in the main package and it
can also be used in production code
mutation testing I didn't mention that
too extensively very powerful technique
to find gaps in your code base we are
now running them manually
uh with what's the name of the library
Striker yes with a with a y yeah we want
to make that part of the maybe at least
consider that because they can be quite
slow they're very useful if you run them
on your production database or your
production codes I'll keep saying
databases sorry I'm currently in the
Oracle project so that changes
everything
um but it really will surface all kinds
of books here code base can be very very
valuable just like property-based
testing that was presented today
uh dependency management yeah I was
always looking for ways to make sure
that somebody doesn't accidentally
create coupling between different
components and packages there's a
library called Arc unit which I haven't
used myself I only read the
documentation which allows you to create
unit tests that verify that certain the
namespaces are not used in certain other
namespaces in the long long time ago
there was something called independent
while still exists but I'm not using
anymore it was too complicated this
looks like you've basically expressed
that dependency or the West to not have
that in C sharp which can be useful
that's something I want to look at
um maybe good to know jetbrains is also
building their own sonar Cube which the
sonar guys here at the floor will
probably not like uh web piloting
because yeah we're good friends with
with your brains it's I think I'm not
sure if it's even public anymore of yet
but there's something to check it out
yourself I've used sonar cube a lot it's
very valuable but the support was
sometimes not on par
and as I said dokie showers I spelled it
wrong but the thing to make it easier to
build your own website because the big
family Jekyll that I'm using it you're
supposed to actually import The Jackal
template as some kind of file so that
you can always update it with new
features but yeah I went I I started to
change everything I cannot do anymore so
we would like to see if that's an option
to make your internal websites on your
on your your packages a lot easier
because yeah you can put your
documentation on Confluence and
everything else but ideally you keep it
close to your repository we do that with
apis where you use open API Swagger why
can't we do this with the the functional
documentation on your your package as
well
so I think that's it
I hope there was something useful for uh
that you haven't seen before uh I'll be
around you can reach me through all
these different channels
um
yeah if there's any questions Now's the
Time but uh yeah maybe totally okay to
do it tonight after we have drunk some
beer or something like that
hope that you enjoyed it uh good luck
enjoy the rest of the conference and
happy to see so many people showing up
thank you
[Applause]